I see people afraid of the rain I say
boy you're afraid of life there's so
much more that I could have done to push
myself in the direction of my dreams
that I didn't you choose one thing and
you dominate that one thing do the thing
you fear the most and fear will move out
of the way say yes I'm gonna fail yes
this is not gonna work out yes this is
gonna be a complete failure oh I don't
feel so good today get your lazy sick
ass up out of bed
negative comes into my mind sometimes
the weirdest things it's like I really
don't know why this keeps popping up a
life without challenge a life without
pain is a life without growth I'm not
the king of everything if my help is not
right mine my help is priority hey dude
I told you to jump 20 years ago you
still didn't jump did you how do you
feel about yourself he's a professional
strongman and strength coach he's known
for his YouTube Fitness channel called
strength camp he has a second popular
YouTube channel called Elliot said what
he's Elliott Hulse and here are top 10
rules for success I see people afraid of
the rain I say boy you're afraid of life
that's really what you're scared of
you're scared of feeling your body is
each one of these is a shot to my
nervous system and then the wind come
and the wind just freezes it upon my
body I love the way this feels man
I only feel like that's why I'm not
afraid of pain that's why I'm not afraid
to take risks
not because I'm courageous because I'm
crazy about life I love the way life
feels on me I like the way it feels your
life is happening to me I don't
necessarily always have to be in control
of life and take it by the horns I like
life carrying me around shock me I want
life this shock does that agree I want
to feel it for each one of my floors in
retrospect there's an adult now today
knowing what I know the experiences that
I've had in the technology that's
available to us I realized that I could
have done a lot more there's so much
more that I could have done to push
myself in the direction of my dreams
that I didn't I held back and even to
this day I so regretful and there's so
much in me that is that there's pain
associated with my not putting forth all
the effort that's associated with
reaching for striving and achieving the
deepest most powerful expression of
strength through me that I've dedicated
my life for supporting other people and
becoming the strongest version of
themselves there's absolutely no reason
on the face of the earth that you should
not reach for every single bright star
in your horizon give everything that
you've got to be that because it's been
given to you you were infused with that
inspiration for a reason now I realize I
didn't reach the pinnacle of my
performance when it came to football but
I've been able to take that
use the motivation use the feeling
associated with achieving that
particular goal and directed towards
supporting young guys coming up so that
they can reach their goals so that you
can become strong aspersion yourself -
Stace is a tool for me to support you
I'm reading a really fascinating book
right now called
the one thing can't remember the name of
the author right now but you can look it
up on Amazon and this author asserts and
and I found this to be true in my own
experience and that's why I find the
book so fascinating he asserts that if
you put all of your eggs in one basket
like Andrew Carnegie once said and just
watch that basket grow you will reach
your greatest success and that basically
means you choose one thing and you
dominate that one thing and it will if
you choose the right thing and we'll
talk about that a moment if you choose
the right one or what I've also heard
described as or called the keystone
habit you choose the habit that's
associated with dominating one thing it
will inevitably trickle over into all
other areas of your life you will see
success in other areas if you just
dominate this one thing it's also been
described as the Pareto principle or the
80/20 rule that whereby all of yours
they say 80% of your results will come
from 20% of your efforts the trick is to
try to figure out what is that 20%
require you know which one of these
things do i hack hack at you know put
all my time effort energy talent and
faculty into dominating so that it will
have a tremendous effect on everything
else do the thing you fear the most and
fear will move out of the way
it's that it's always that thing that
you're not too sure about all that you
fear that I often think is the direction
you should go into so I tell the young
people and sometimes this is
irresponsible advice but I look it's
just been my experience and Emerson
could gnomes by saying that that's a
quote
that if you've got two choices about
where you want to go next and this is
the well-trodden path in other words it
seems like it's stable it seems like
there is stability safety security in
this particular direction and this one
is a mystery take the mystery because if
you will you will never regret taking
action in the direction of your dreams
regardless of what it gives you because
the experience always enhances you as
opposed to taking that well trodden path
living a life that truly isn't yours but
was handed to you or carved out for you
take the road less traveled you've got
to embrace failure because failure is
the soil that brings forth the plants of
success in other words when every
failure is the seed for success you
cannot succeed without failure in the
same way that a tree cannot grow if you
don't bury the seed in the soil right so
be ok with it say yes I'm gonna fail yes
this is not gonna work out yes this is
gonna be a complete failure you know I
do this all the time I put up these
videos sometimes and I'm like oh that
video sucked it's a failure people
aren't gonna like it right but I do it
anyway because I'm gonna make another
one when I make another one I'm gonna
make another one I'm gonna make another
one and one of them is bound to be good
so make more mistakes make more failures
keep going the idea is to just shut your
brain off because that's what the thing
the thing is you're neurotic or thinking
too much
shut your brain off and just do it
anyway screw it up big time I tell this
to people all the time if you're going
up to a girl that you'd like to speak to
and you've never done this before
be prepared to the whole thing up be
prepared to do it completely wrong but
be prepared to do it because you're
gonna learn something from that failure
you're gonna go and talk to her and
she's gonna say get away from me you
loser
right and you're gonna say ah next time
I should probably pick my eyes up when I
talk to her right you pick up a tip then
you do it again you'll pick up another
tip pick up another tip the idea is that
failure is your tool failures is the
evolution towards being a stronger
version of yourself you
to fail embrace failure love failure
fail as many times as you possibly can
so that you can get one step closer to
having this thing happen
oh I don't feel so good today get your
lazy sick ass up out of bed reason why
you don't feel so good today is because
you eatin begin with a simple step die
it's a tough one because it's all day
long you know going to school and
passing your tests you'll set the
appointment and make it getting your
foot fixed set the appointment and make
it diet that's all day long begin simple
my man drink water revolutionize your
life by drinking water don't go crazy
with all the diet information out there
there's a hundred and one different
diets and they all contradict themselves
and if you follow this one and then two
weeks later you read a blog post or you
see a video about that one you get all
this a DD book going on which ah boy
choose to drink water say I will drink
half my body weight in ounces of water a
day no matter what it does not matter if
you're choking on the water who filled
your belly up so much it's gonna burst
drink the water
this requires a warrior mindset and I
think that's a part of what's lacking
it's interesting you know the more and
more I read these questions and more and
more I meet you guys the more and more
I'm realizing we ain't got enough
warriors in this culture you guys are
addicted lovers that's why I keep
finding addicted lovers and in clever
magicians maybe if you wouldn't follow
my videos you know my metaphors addicted
lovers meaning like oh I love this
oh I'm passionate about this oh I love
that huh and it's like there's this just
I've keep falling in love with different
things and you never get anything done
and the clever the clever magician is
the cynic who holds everything at a
distance well I know all about that hey
they're the best commenters here oh I
know all about that that he's wrong and
I'm right but you know what you're the
eyes that don't try anything because
you're just sitting in your dark caves
wizarding about different things and
thinking and reading and flipping
through your your books
there's more information about stuff I
can't do anything yet I still have to
learn where are the Warriors let's say
I'm going to make a decision and I'm
keeping it
devotion discipline where is that devote
yourself to something bigger be decisive
about what you gonna do say I'm gonna do
it and that's it and then be disciplined
about getting it done every single day
whether you feel like it or not it's no
poetic saying that you become what you
think about and that the world is your
mirror
we are literally creating our world
through the thoughts that we Harbor and
it begins in how our body responds to
the things that we think about and if
you think depressive things your body
your energy becomes depressed right if
you're thinking negative things can you
smile and laugh and tell jokes and go
run around in circles with children and
play and dance right you can't do it
because you got depressive thoughts and
if you're really excited can you help
yourself
like if someone tells you you need to
sit down and shut up and and bottle it
all in but you're like it's the night
before Christmas like a little kid a
little kid to sit down during like
Christmas like put Christmas presents or
presents birthday present in front of
them or say sit there they can't help
but get sytems gonna burst out so your
body responds to your thoughts what's
going on is gonna show up in your body
it's right in the end and this is just
my reiteration of the fact that the body
is the mind and we begin with the body
so now how do we control the thoughts
coming in and out of our heads negative
thoughts that are that you are now a
victim of right because the thoughts
were victimizing you they come in like a
virus and they take over just like you
know any other pathogen right right you
you get a stomach bug and it gets Enya
and that's it you're [ __ ] until he
takes medicine to get it out well
thoughts are an interesting thing
because like I alluded to before we have
to entertain them in order for them to
have any power now consider this term
entertain someone comes to your door
right you're your mom you haven't seen
your mom in a very long time or or an
old friend comes to the door your old
friend comes to door and you you invite
him into your house and now what do you
do you entertain you offer energy in his
direction hey would you like something
to drink sure hey have a seat this is my
favorite chair I'd like you to try it
out hey check it out when you lean it
back do you see how comfortable that is
Oh I'll call my wife Colleen did some of
that dip that you made last night we
have any of that left we'd like to
entertain our friend with some
nourishing food hey what kind of movies
do you like I've got a whole DVD
collection people don't have DVD
collections anymore we have Netflix and
Hulu have you seen that movie yet let's
let's sit down and watch it by the way
let's have a beer while we watch it
that's entertaining someone who comes
into your home a friendly person who
you'd like to have around for a while
and allow them to grow roots for a
moment there are certain thoughts that
make their way into the home of your
consciousness they knock on the door
your first choice is to either let them
in I mean before entertaining you got to
let it in let the thoughts in or close
the door Google slam the door shut okay
the way that looks is I get negative
thoughts I get negative thoughts Eliot
house gets negative thoughts negative
comes into my mind sometimes the
weirdest things that's like I really
don't know why this keeps popping up
here's one I keep having this one that
I'm going to get into a car accident I
don't know why it's a new one but I keep
thinking that I'm not gonna be paying
attention when I'm driving and I'm my
car is gonna demolished
for whatever reason that keeps knocking
in my door maybe I should pay attention
to it I wear my seatbelt right maybe
that's what it is it's warning but on
your seatbelt and don't check your phone
while you're driving
take heed but I don't let it in such
that I saw it obsessing over car
accidents and I become a nervous wreck
while I'm driving I don't start watching
videos about car wrecks and when the
news on the news when there is a car
accident I start could have been me I
don't entertain the thought I don't go
home and start talking about car wrecks
and potentials for dying in a car
accident with my wife and my friends
because I'm not entertaining the thought
he came to the door I peeked I say oh Sh
and I walked away he goes away now
sometimes oftentimes because I attract
them beautiful thoughts come in my goals
I'd like to achieve you know what I'd
like one day not because I need it that
because I'm greedy not for anything but
the fact that I know I can do it I want
one of those Mercedes G classes that's
the six-figure car looks like a Jeep I
don't have to have this thing I'm not
making myself notic but it's a nice
thought that when it comes to my do it
when it comes to my window I say huh
come on in and I look at pictures and I
go on and I see how much it costs and I
Drive by the Mercedes dealership and I
see it in there and one day I might go
in there and I might sit in SA look sir
I can't afford one of you but boy I'd
like to sit in it I'm entertaining the
thought and guess what
I'm smiling my body feels good I am
receptive to it watch my videos long
enough I'll tell you what I have it and
I won't have to break my ass for it
because it happens just by entertaining
it pain is a beautiful thing challenge
is what life is about a life without
challenge a life without pain is a life
without growth and where there is no
growth there is stale stagnant energy
and that's where most people live
because most people's lives
are designed around treading a path that
is void of challenge the minute they
recognize challenge or pain they move
the other way this is a primal instinct
and normal and natural but a weak
perspective most people are bored if you
ask them what do you think about your
life same old same old every single day
what it was the thing same day same
different day things of this nature
that's because they're living their
lives in a lie that is shrouded in
comfort it doesn't exist they're not
challenged they're not growing they are
bored and they're better off dead your
likeness is found in your pain embrace
it love it and grow from it I knew and
you know being king of the king of
everything Elliott Hulse my health has
to be right I'm not the king of
everything if my health is not right my
health is priority number one then
family dog relationships love not all
you guys have family but I knew that
when when when my dad challenged me with
you can't be everything one of the
challenges was oh you want to be a you
want to be a business owner you want to
be an entrepreneur you want to be a
tough guy who can go out there and
succeed to make a lot of money but make
sure that you take care of your family
because if you take care of all that
others your family is not taken care of
then you're a loser then you're a fake
your Fugazi you're falling short and you
ain't making it happen like a true king
of everything
so I knew right away that like yo if I'm
gonna design his business lifestyle
right is that cool that's the third when
we'll talk about in a minute but if I
was in design my lifestyle in general
let's begin with what we have health
number one then I have to fit it around
I have to work it with and I has to
dance amongst things like family I
should pick out some body builders you
know pick out some power lifters you
know they can pick out some any obsessed
athlete that you know and look at their
family if they can balance their family
their family's well taken care of the
wife is satisfied and their children are
respectful then you tell me what you
have on your hand ladies and gentlemen
is the making of a king hey we got this
fun an interesting question from our
buddy 19 years old just started working
out he's eating right starting to feel
his body's the way he describes it and
and he's excited about the progress he's
making but one thing that he's noticed
is that because he's getting up earlier
and he's exercising and you know
exerting himself in that way he finds
that about halfway through the day he
gets tired and of course it's kind of
normal you're doing more so your body's
going to require more cultivation and
that's fine that's normal natural the
thing is he says that he discovered
something really interesting or we had
an experience and he's wondering is this
real he says I got done with my workout
one day earlier this week I got done
with my workout and I figured I'd go
home and be tired like I typically end
after a long day of becoming the
strongest version of myself and uh on my
way out I noticed a really hot chick I
said to myself you know what I'm feeling
pretty damn confident I'm gonna go and
introduce myself to her he goes and
introduce himself to his hot girl on his
way out of the gym and he says it was a
complete mess completely fell apart you
know he tried his best but like really
she wasn't interested but it didn't
matter because he discovered something
even more important he said I was more
energized for the rest of that day than
I can remember ever being energized
normally I be tired but after subjecting
myself to this dangerous experience by
being courageous with this young girl I
was animated for the rest of the day I
had more energy than ever before Eliott
yeah so let me give you a specific
question towards the end of his email
says do you believe that doing things
you're afraid to do makes you feel more
alive and gives you energy well my
friend you stumbled upon a essential
principle of all these videos that I
create and a lot of people think I'm
completely irresponsible and out of my
mind and nuts when I tell young men to
go and do dangerous to trust and the
most dangerous thing is to trust your
heart and your heart sure you towards
girl and what was the experience a
complete mess right guess what most of
the time when you're courageous enough
to follow your heart in the beginning
and perhaps for quite some time it's
gonna be a complete mess I know this
that's why I often say you don't take
the call to adventure you don't follow
your heart you don't do the thing that
your body's telling you to do because of
what you're going again you do it
because of who you're gonna become right
my friend
and how did you become after
experiencing that dangerous moment by
subjecting yourself to that experience
that was dangerous because mind you
stresses stress regardless there's going
to be a physiological response in your
body to stress
regardless if it's you're jumping out of
a helicopter or you're talking to a hot
girl what kind of person will you
afterwards
animated you're more vibrant vital alive
energetic ready to go
you're becoming stronger version of
yourself because of that and what
happens is that the stress is a unique
type of stress and I've heard it
described this way of course there's
stress and there's a physiological
response to the stress but there's a
different color to distress and you
stress now I don't know if you stress eu
stress is an actual word but the person
who shared it with me was trying to
combine the terror
you for euphoric right it's euphoric
with stress you stress distress is a
kind of nagging chronic stress where
you're constantly anxious because you
can't pay your bills or you'll never get
the career that you want or you'll never
live up to your daddy's expectations and
you go about life with this nagging
distress that ultimately leads to your
demise that just stresses you out rose
you older and more degenerated over time
that's where that's the stress that most
people deal with you stress is a
completely different phenomenon there's
a physiological response to it in your
body which is sympathetic that's why you
felt so energetic but it's colored with
euphoria because of what you're becoming
you just exercise what I believe to be
the iron quality in becoming the
strongest version yourself and that is
courage and the experience was a
complete mess but you're growing you see
this distress makes you sick and dying
you stress creates growth and that's why
I often say go do dangerous right now
because Elliott Hulse is a douchebag and
he's trying to give that advice to young
men but because I know that when you
jump off that cliff and your only
intention is to fly before you hit the
bottom
you're gonna animate all your vital
resources to learn how to fly on the way
down and that's why you have to jump you
know there's a different type of
response to that cliff that a lot of
people most people experience and that
is they stare down that cliff their
entire lives until they're like 40 45 50
and the guy they call this midlife
crisis this is when you've committed to
all of the trappings notice that we're
trappings trappings traps of the world
now you got a family you've got a
business you've got a career you've got
a boss you got taxes they can't jump
dude because you're too trapped by the
trappings of the world now my book I say
you still joke but anyway the point is
but if you stand there you just keep
look
down that get into that chasm and it
begins you know you reach the edge of
that cliff when you're 25 years old
guess what you're gonna live with for
the next 25 years distress that kills
you because you didn't jump there's that
part of you that's always tapping you
hey dude I told you to jump 20 years ago
you still didn't jump did you how do you
feel about yourself well I've got a
hundred thousand dollars in my bank
account man who gives it
my wife's hot that gives it I got
children to take care who gives it you
should have jumped when I told you to
jump and now you gotta live with it
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because Captain Awesome asked
us to now if you have a famous
entrepreneur you would like profile
leave a comment below I'd also love to
know which of Elliott's top ten rules
hit you the hardest leaving the comments
below will join the discussion thank you
so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon
you
mm sometimes you got to do the things
that are necessarily aligned with your
core values to get you to where you go
now
mean that you've got a lie cheat and
steal but to balance your for directions
like I often talk about you know you use
the sharpened intelligence deepens
intuition expanding love and your your
your aggressive action or that sometimes
especially in the beginning stages of
trying to get the ball rolling
aggressive action just takes everything
oftentimes becomes your your magician
and your warrior love get set set aside
and order off and get set aside because
you're doing what you have to do to get
it done as the ball begins rolling as
you start gaining a level of success
come back to your core values widen
began in the beginning
okay oftentimes we make our passions are
our business and you knew you mentioned
yesterday might not be a good idea
because what happens then is the thing
that you want slow now becomes a job
right and that's when the mission is a
warrior completely you know just in an
imbalance way taking things to where it
needs to go so that there's some sort of
movement right but once the ball is
rolling step back for a moment it's just
been my experience come back to your
core values and why you're doing the
thing that you're doing or fall back in
love with it because there's a tendency
to fall out of love with it when it
becomes your business and then start
proceeding from that place brings a love
back into you so your conviction matters
far more than what you do or even what
your idea is to be a tremendous leader
means that you first lead yourself
become fully enrolled and strengthen
your conviction in whatever it is that
you choose and then the method just
happens you don't have to follow a
step-by-step formula
right you don't have to grab in control
although that is a method you've got a
Jesus or a muhammad jesus flips tables
and tells you come follow me
Muhammad goes in and breaks all the
statues and tells you what to think and
you've got a Buddha who sits under a
tree and waits for you to come equally
convinced that their ideal is the one so
to cut to the chase grow your own
strength of conviction and the path
toward leadership will be unveiled don't
copy or follow in anyone's footsteps
strengthen your own feet and stop your
own ground don't be afraid to fail get
out there and do your my invitations
always go and experience life instead of
reading about it go and experience life
instead of asking someone else to tell
you how to live life go out there and
fail go out there and scrape your knees
go out there and do the wrong thing that
way you now have an experience that acts
as a tool to support you in the building
of your life everybody wants our truth
we as individuals and as parents and as
the world about it respects insurance
and security and safety to such a great
degree does not afford you the power of
your own subjective experience my
invitation is always to ignore everyone
and try for yourself trust yourself
believe in yourself
go out there and be all that you can be
regardless of what anyone else has to
say about it because people are trying
to keep you down they want you to stay
in that little category that they've
created for you and you've got to
transcend that you've got to trust
yourself courage is the virtue that
allows that to happen so be courageous